there's something from the website
MarketWatch it says Bill Maher and Drew
Barrymore recently announced plans to
resume their shows amid the Hollywood's
writers and actors strike drawing
backlash from Union officials and public
figures alike marho's Real Time with
Bill Maher and HBO while Barrymore is uh
behind the syndicated Drew Barrymore
show Omar who announced his decision
Wednesday said in a post on Twitter that
it's time to bring people back to work
and that much of his staff is struggling
mightily Lamar also said that he will
honor the spirit of the strike by not
doing a monologue or his popular new
rules segment
in other words elements of the show that
require writers still Union leadership
didn't take kindly to Mar and
Barrymore's decision The Writer's Guild
said Wednesday that Mars plan to return
was disappointing and the union has
already picketed tapings of Barrymore's
show
um Frank Lieberman an entertainment
executive told MarketWatch that there's
no question some people in the industry
are indeed hurting financially you need
to find work
but he also thinks that the decisions by
Mar and Barrymore go beyond that it's
all about greed he said
okay so I have uh this is the story is
worth mentioning I thought but I have no
dog in this fight of course I don't care
either way
um
if the Hollywood writers get everything
they want in this dispute that's been
going on for however many months now
they get everything they want out of it
then fine if they get nothing that they
want out of it that is also fine don't
care either way it's hard to assess who
deserves what because on the one hand
you've got the Hollywood Studios
and they are they're the ones
they are who the strike is targeting
um and the Hollywood Studios it's not
like anyone has any sympathy for them I
mean they're Godless cesspools on the
other hand Hollywood writers these days
are awful unoriginal unoriginal
untalented
the the in many ways they could not have
timed this strike worse they're going to
be worse timing
because most of them are so bad at their
job I mean the the writing in Hollywood
is just terrible these days
so all you can really do in this match I
guess is root for injuries
metaphorically metaphorically I mean
this is a game where you're just rooting
for interest because you can't you can't
root for either side that said you do
see the kind of inherent
um selfishness of these sorts of strikes
and organized labor protests
and why it's always
absurd when you hear from these people
that that they care about you know the
The Working Man and this is all about
Justice and all the rest of it no it's
not
the people the writers picketing outside
they don't care about Justice
they don't care about helping people who
are hurting I don't care about any of
that
because you've got
thousands of other people
who are not part of this strike
and are not going to benefit from any of
the concessions that you may extract
and all of them are out of work
I mean the Bill Maher's show there's
dozens of other people who are not
writers
who work on that show and rely on it for
an income obviously
you know
um
and and they're not making an income
right now and they don't benefit at all
from any of this
and if the writers get whatever they're
asking for and I don't even know what
they're asking for because I don't care
if they get whatever they ask for these
other people are not going to see any of
those benefits
and so they want to get back to work so
they can feed their families
and then the the writers on strike have
the audacity
to be angry about it it's like how dare
you feed your own families
I'm trying to get a raise over here
well as many of you know I am going to
be on Dancing With the Stars not only am
I excited for this show but I am
thrilled to be bringing my dog for one
of the dances that's right we're
announcing that right now and thanks to
rough greens my pup will be able to keep
up the energy that we need on the Dance
Floor naturopathic Dr Dennis black the
founder of rough grains focused on
improving the health of every dog in
America a little did I know before I got
rough greens dog food is dead food
everybody knows nutrition isn't Brown
it's green well rough greens boost your
dog's food back to life rough grain is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just sprinkle rough Greens on
their food every day dog owners
everywhere are raving about rough greens
it supports healthy joints improves bad
breath boosts energy levels and so much
more we are what we eat and that goes
for dogs too naturopathic Dr Dennis
black is so confident rough greens will
improve your dog's health he's offering
my listeners a free jump start trial bag
so your dog can try it a free jumpstart
trial bag could be at your door just a
few business days go to roughgreens.com
Matt or call 844 rough 700 that's Ruff
greens.com Matt or call 844 rough 700
today
that's what a strike is like you want to
raise you want your own money
and so you're gonna make everybody else
suffer
not the bosses like the Hollywood studio
bosses they're not they don't care
they obviously don't care that's why
they're not that's why they're gonna let
this strike continue
they got they got money to burn you're
not hurting that many
you're hurting everybody else
who are not millionaires many of them
make less money than you do as a writer
on these shows
they have no concern about that at all
they don't care if you'd like to see
what else I have to say you can access
my full show by going to dailywire.com
or by going to the Matt Walsh Show
Twitter page hope to see you there
Godspeed